als die kiste ist weg oli nein das ist
die challenge ich praktisch strings weg
leute unser inventar leert sich
bald geht's an die rüstung sehr spitz
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge heute spielen wir mai kräftig aber
nicht einfach so nein wir haben heute
eine besondere challenge und die lautet
wie folgt die habe ich mir selbst
ausgedacht und zwar ich glaube bevor ich
ursprünglich die erstmal und die geht so
jedes mal wenn ich einen film mache also
wenn ich aus der map falle und respawn
muss muss ich ein item wegwerfen so das
ist die challenge ich sag mal bei foot
zählt es nur wenn man alle items einer
sorte wegschmeißt also bei foot muss man
dann zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt fünf
kekse hat kann ich nicht sagen oh ich
fall einmal runter ich werde einen keks
weg da muss ich alles von einer sorte
wegschmeißen und ich nehme trotzdem
keine bullshit items also wie zum
beispiel das rotten flesh mitnehmen
machen das alles ganz locker sehr schön
erstes modul ohne fehler abgeschlossen
das könnte eine ziemlich ziemlich
schwierige challenge sein wenn ich
zwischendurch mal so einen punkt habe wo
ich hänge ich hoffe dazu kommt es nicht
ich spiel jetzt einfach richtig
vorsichtig leute damit das hier gut
läuft damit ich nicht allzu viel stoff
werk werfen muss momentan hätte ich ein
bisschen juli schüttete ein bisschen
equipment um das zu kompensieren zum
beispiel jetzt das holzschwert da hätte
ich noch mein zweites holzschwert und
ich hab's gesehen ich habe auch meine
holzdecke worauf man sich behalten
das zeug auch nicht wenn es unsinnig ist
wir machen das man bis schön knackig
hier die alten sachen wenn weggeworfen
wenn sie ersetzt werden es sei denn sie
sind natürlich jetzt besonders guter
sondern weil ich das nicht mache aber
soweit glaube ich dass das eine richtig
heftige challenge werden könnte also ich
müsste jetzt zum beispiel bei strings
ist es glaube ich auch das gleiche also
wenn jetzt runter fallen dann muss ich
nicht ein string droppen sondern alle
drei strings auf einmal und ich hab das
ist eine ziemlich ziemlich heftige
challenge wenn es nachher bisschen
knackiger wird jetzt am anfang ich mich
gar nicht so blöd an
ich glaube ich bin vom mega fokus
ich habe richtig schiss davor
runterzufallen ich bin nicht meine items
weggeben meister angel
ja man nicht es kommen gleich wird
gleich zu gleich zwei gleich wird's
richtig wehtun
oje oje leute junge weil ich auch
richtig auf darunter nada ist es das
erste alte muss weg das holzschwert die
weg warten wenn ich jetzt runter fallen
cs nicht genau deswegen
ich muss erstmal hier das wort wirklich
an sorgen dass es auch aus dem map raus
ist soll jetzt geht es jetzt jetzt hilft
wieder nein jetzt geht's los jetzt
hängig rechtes kopf web oder die kopie
ich glaub ich wirklich cookies weg die
cookies sind das item was ich am
wenigsten brauche hier ja sehr schön
das geht aber noch das hier ist der tat
sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön
man könnte vielleicht doch ein führen
dass man brauche ich so gerne mit ich
nehme ich alles mit hier junge mann
könnte eventuell finde dass man für ein
checkpoint irgendwie ein item
gutgeschrieben kriegt aber so dass auch
bisschen leben machen sachen mal so ganz
straight
ich muss jetzt richtig konzentriert
spielen
oje oje oje das war schon mal dass
kosten gleich mein leben scheiße nice
die stadt wird weggeworfen
jetzt konzentriert spielt konzentriere
dich konzentrierst geld es ist eine
schwierige challenge aber du kannst es
schaffen nein
junge und es sollten wir hier oben
liegen irgendwie es packt sich immer auf
dem blog hat ihn gesehen
nein das ist so fies man wenn man
hierunter fällt ist man halt sofort weg
oder kartoffeln mais gut junge junge
junge junge
junge junge junge das wird es heute kein
speedrun weil ich einfach mega vorsieht
die spielen muss mega vorsichtig
vielleicht so so kommt man eigentlich
rankommen oder hier also ich das aber
oder man kommt nicht dran
man kommt so nicht an die kiste daran
dass das heißt ich komme jetzt gar nicht
mehr in die kiste alter schwierig kam
aus mikrobereich kommt gar nicht mehr in
die kiste jetzt steht es sei denn ich
nie wenn ich jetzt runter fall ich habe
schon geschäft dann bin ich raus dann
respawn informiert das heißt die kiste
ist weg nein das ist die challenge ich
packe die strings weg leute unser
inventar leert sich
bald geht's ab bald geht's an die
rüstung ich für euch bald geht's an die
rostocker mit ihr das zeug wegschmeißen
junge so heftig da vorne ist mal wieder
eine safety ist da kommentieren
nämlich die hier richtig spaß man oh ja
sehr schön wieder ein bisschen sda fleiß
und eisen barren übte schon im ziel
der ist schon im ziel junge das ist gut
das ist gut für uns warum springe ich da
überhaupt noch
warum spricht überhaupt noch ich kann
nicht nicht den food wegwerfen
ich muss das jetzt alles entsorgen ist
okay ich noch diesen monat das damit ich
muss was den sorgen ja ok hat wird
durchweg packen ich kann ich habe nur
noch airport shops nicht wegschmeißen
online only been noch mehr hits alter
schwede
alter schwede nein nein macht nicht
machen ich noch nicht junge danke dass
mich gewartet hast du kann ich mich
selber umdrehen
oh je oh je tiefer man in scharnstein
schwert 625 schadens punkte alter
schwede
das death match wieder so richtig
schwierig das wird es richtig schwierig
was mir nicht aufpasst haben wir auch
kein tnt
vielleicht wenn ich mir einen pfeil
drücke ich brauch vorliegen dringend
food es wird echt knapp
wenn ich ihm einen pfeil drücke könnte
es reichen wenn ich mir dann vielleicht
noch eine combo gebe nein
junge wie viel leben der hatte
eigentlich bin ich mehr hits gegeben und
er trotz alter schwede war heftig wo
gott jetzt muss ich aufpassen also der
ist schon mal richtig op ich habe
natürlich schon gesehen dass die politik
mit hat aber dass er so ps nicht
unbedingt jetzt kommt s auctions tnt
geil als er es direkt wieder da mit ihr
noch ein leben
da fordert kein gutes equipment doch ist
es wieder der es ist wieder der junge
warum gerade ich immer an den nein der
macht nicht so richtig fertig london
jetzt muss ich für die runde gewinnt
egal welches team challenge mache mich
nicht einfach so ging in einen typen der
abgucken habe ich keinen bock drauf
notfalls zusätzliche 2 1 gegen 1
dennoch dreileben kein leben verloren
ok dann macht das eigentlich wenig sind
gegen den pfeiler einzusetzen weil ich
nicht an seiner kühnen komme mit was
können wir machen wir können einfach
ewig weggelaufen vor dem und dann wenn
es gar nicht mehr weitergeht dann
kämpfen wir einfach aber jo bevor der
will uns auch richtig seht ihr dass der
will uns richtig wir uns targeted alter
guckt euch das an und ob es gibt zwei
von der sorte nein nicht die uno leute
nein das ist nicht euer ernst das ist
nicht euer ernst
was war das denn das ist nicht euer
ernst
drei leute waren da und die zwei mit den
scharfen schwertern gehen auf mich alter
schwede
okay da muss man einfach mal hinnehmen
dass es nicht man kann die runden nicht
immer gewinnen auch wenn es mir schon
weh tut in jump league sieglos davon zu
gehen aber alter schwede teams verboten
sagt er mit recht diesen richtig zu
folgen ist man 2 von der sorte heftig
aber okay leute welche change gefallen
hat dann probiert jedoch selbst mal zu
hause aus und schreibt man die
kommentare wie es bei euch so läuft
lassen wie sie es beim nächsten video
hat rein macht's gut und